convicted terrorist mohammed hassanah
ooh
that ring some bells
from a juvenile when my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro was picky to the nighties
moshino
i was having some tea
and some biscuits hello i'm about it
uh with the family uh and breaking news
it is breaking news i feel like a
newscast now
a new you know a news center yes so
somebody sent me this and i was thinking
what's that about and it was really the
following
popular man convicted terrorists caught
in 200 000 rohingya muslim swindle
thinking terrorist rohingya didn't
really ring bells
so let's read further brothers and
sisters together inshallah here we go
convicted terrorist mohammed hasan
that ring some bells hasn't
yes guys hasanat has been convicted
let's carry a reason inshallah
committed serious hassan has been caught
swindling the public out of two hundred
thousand pounds that he and his
comp accomplice ms roxanna ali claimed
was to provide aid for rohingya muslims
in myanmar
and bangladesh while you're doing
nothing but
putting fire in your stomach what you
did is nothing but
fire in your stomach literally
you guys should ask for repentance
that's if you guys are still um
believe if you're muslim because we know
it is not anyways
another video has a night resident in
blast street popular at the time the
terrorist crimes occurred
pleaded guilty to four charges of
terrorism in june 2012 and was sentenced
to 14 months imprisonment
most of these people are troubled people
i've had personal experience with these
people most of them they do not practice
their religion they don't even i was
talking to one and i was telling them
about traveler prayer he didn't know
what travel the prayer was he was
thinking well what's that
joining i was like yeah i'm trying to
pray from swimming i was like what are
you talking about
they are that ignorant and he was what
was he charged for look read carefully
four charges of terrorism in june 2012
and sentenced to 14 months imprisonment
the charges related to
relating to having copies of al qaeda
macazee magazine inspired on this
computer
rohingya muslim fraud and ali created a
your your caring account now part of
gofundme in july 2017
and up until a charity commission
inquiry started in 2019 forced foster
claimed to be fundraising
neither created a proper registered
charity and instead deposited money
raised in six personal accounts
and one paypal account it's a panel like
these orphans
these orphans the money that you took
you've done nothing but
fire in your stomach like allah total
charitable funds raised and held within
the multiple accounts amounted to 213
898 pounds and 60p when the accounts
were frozen by the charity commission as
part of his inquiry the balance was
around
nine pound 145 nine p leaving sixty
eight thousand seven hundred and forty
eight pounds eighty
one p unaccounted for god knows what
kind of uh business class flights they
went to maybe so panel
the charity commission could not confirm
if any charitable expenditure had
actually occurred
so this is why he was charged with
terrorism yeah so um
gay free zone hate campaign in 2011
hasanat was also involved in the gay
free zone hate campaign in tower hamlets
he pleaded guilty to a public order
offense and was fined 100 pounds
plus 85 pound cost and the 15 pound
victim surcharge
after he put up posters around the
borough declaring it's a gay frieza
can you imagine this is their tower this
people this is their tower going
stabbing
i'm not seeing him the people that
follow him i go and stabbing people on
the innocent people on the road
and put in gay frieza marshall sharia
came establish sharia
in yourself first before you go and do
that but it's okay
it's easy to go and do silly things like
that you know and you think you're doing
something you're serving the religion of
allah yeah
anyways be warned mohammed hassanat
named first surface when he was found
guilty of participating in this
notorious gay free zone hate campaign
and again when he was convicted for
terrorism-related offences says popular
resident jack gilbert who is current
chair of lansbury ward panel and
former ceo of rainbow hamlets now it
appears he is pocketing the hard-earned
donations of local people in the name of
charity
local people in popular and lansbury
does not need such evil people in our
midst
be warned funds given to real charities
alhamdulillah the charity commission
at the conclusion of the investigation
the frozen funds were given by the
charity commission to two rocking their
charities which actually do what they
claim to do
alhamdulillah and brahman sisters i'm
going to end on that i'm not here to
hold you guys too much and the thing is
you know your accountability in this
life
going doing maybe community service or
going in jail or whatever
it's my news to what to wait for you in
the hereafter
if you don't repent and if allah doesn't
have mercy you're new and unless the
most merciful repent
but if you don't repent may allah
protect us that's what i'm going to say
brother and sisters
how evil how evil was the panel that and
we was looking up to these people oh no
i wish i had a husband like that oh i
wish i had a wife like that i was a
bilateral
this is what this is what should teach
us stop comparing your life to other
people
and thinking they've got it better the
glass is greener the glass is not
greener it's fake
till next time brothers and sisters from
alidawah share this wide inshallah
and we ask hasanat and sister roxanna
whoever
inshallah they repent turn to allah and
use this time if they're in jail
to read some quran and you know maybe
turn to their religion inshallah
if not until next time
goodbye